[Music]
Venezuela unveiled its new National map
in December adding an area the size of
Florida to its
territory but this land called the esbo
belongs to Guyana a country rich in gold
and diamonds it is now one of the
world's fastest growing crude oil
producers for more than a century
Venezuela has laid claim to the
territory
ano is practically wiping Guyana off of
them I'm hearing gaka trying to
understand and more about president
maduro's plans to take over this land
and what it means in this region as
these two oil rich countries
Clash the dispute for the esoko dates
back to the 19th century when Great
Britain acquired Guyana and expanded its
territory to the west but Venezuela
protested saying the esao was part of
its territory under Spanish
rule tensions between the two countries
intensified in 19 1966 when Guyana
gained independence from Britain Guyana
has since sought a resolution through
the international court of justice but
Venezuela rejects the
procedure the esbo makes up 2/3 of
Guyana and is mostly covered in
rainforest the territory has large
reserves of gold and diamonds asba
region contribute to the country's
economic wealth our forest is an
important resource we have large deposit
of gold
reserves but a turning point came in
2015 when oil was found off the esbo
coast since then a Consortium led by the
US oil giant Exxon Mobile said it has
discovered up to 11 billion barrels of
oil and natural gas resources oil
Executives say that this was the largest
discovery of the decade it could give
the country the highest oil output per
capita in the world ahead of oil Rich
Kuwait and Saudi Arabia
Guyana it's interesting because it's a
new producer it's a country where until
2015 no one knew that there was oil and
it has started to produce and is a not
OPEC member which is very important and
it includes its possibility to already
deliver oil to the market in a market
that is restricted because of all the
sanctions that exist to
Russia because of its new found oil
revenues Guyana had the highest real GDP
growth in in the world in
62.3% and the international monetary
fund predicts its GDP will keep
growing Guyana went from one of South
America's poorest countries to having
one of the world's fastest growing
economies we're priced to earn on
average about5 to6 billion do perom by
2035 but Venezuela's president Nicholas
Maduro says the oil reserves in the esbo
belong to his
country while Guyana reaps from the oil
windfall Venezuela's economy has
contracted 80% since Maduro came to
office in
2013 nearly 8 million Venezuelans have
fled in the past decade hundreds of
thousands of them wound up in the
US in order to OU Maduro the US imposed
sanctions on the Venezuelan oil industry
in
2019 the Biden Administration agreed to
temporarily lift some economic sanctions
on Venezuela in October in exchange for
Democratic reforms which include
allowing opposition candidates to run in
this year's presidential
election us officials said that allowing
more oil and gas money to flow in could
help stabilize Venezuela and ease the
large flow of
migrants but when it comes to the eso
dispute Washington is not on Venezuela
aside the state department said it
supports Guyana which has held meetings
with officials from the US defense
department to increase
cooperation in December Venezuela's
government said more than 10 million
voters approved annexing esbo in a
[Music]
referendum election experts have cast
doubts on the veracity of the
results especially in a country where
the government has been accused of
widespread electoral fraud in past
elections
[Applause]
after the referendum Maduro ordered the
country's state-owned companies to
explore and exploit the oil gas and
mines in the eso and told foreign
companies that they have 3 months to
abandon their operations in the region G
of views this as an imminent threat to
its territorial integrity and will
intensify precautionary measures as
tension started to rise the UK sent a
warship to support Guyana and Maduro
responded with air and Naval exercises
near the
border experts said the referendum was
largely a Wag the Dog moment for Maduro
as he tries to Rally nationalist support
ahead of the president itial election
later this
year it's a typical strategy of a
dictator autocrat of finding a problem
to distract people from their reality
which is a completely devastated
economic situation and a horrible
humanitarian
situation the leaders of Guyana and
Venezuela have met to discuss the
annexation and agreed to avoid conflict
but Guyana refused muda's plans to
settle the dispute through bilateral
negotiations asking the UN to intervene
and lay Venezuela's claims to
rest but experts say the case is likely
to drag on for
[Music]
years